cris est relatée culotte blanche
ces jours d'examen pour les à cette
jeune lilloise est arrivé aux jambes aux
il y a deux ans séduite par l'esprit de
communauté de ce lycée unique en france
en fait d'être en internat on est tous
ensemble tout le temps on vit tous les
mêmes choses et puis moi qui est souvent
ici même les week-ends on apprend
vraiment à vivre en communauté tous
ensemble des vraiment à s'occuper des
animaux comme il faut et on les découvre
un peu plus chaque jour
autrefois orphelinat tenu par les soeurs
le lycée du cheval comme on l'appelle a
été créé il y a 20 ans 140 chevaux et
poney cohabitent ici avec 250 élèves du
ceap et de soigneur au bac pro hippiques
en passant par la maréchalerie l'élevage
et le débourrage de jeunes chevaux
le lycée propose de nombreuses
formations avec une véritable
philosophie on parle de l'équithérapie
c'est pas un vain mot
j'aimerais que le cheval permet à chaque
jeune de mieux se connaître lui permet
d'une certaine façon de se
responsabiliser et je dirais que ce sont
autant d'éléments importants aussi pour
la scolarité des enfants pour les high
son cheval horizons c'est parti pour
l'épreuve du bac pro hippiques
un parcours de dix obstacles à effectuer
avec un nombre précis de fouler un
cheval tirés au sort aux ordres calme et
droit entre aussi dans la note
l'analyse du parcours avec le jury
les contrats de poulet sont tous vont
sauf sur la ligne de trois où j'en fais
6 ennemis ou de 6,7
une petite 7e léa qui espère devenir une
professionnelle confirmée est plutôt
satisfait de son parcours très très bien
chez elle était aux ordres
il faisait tout ce que je lui ai demandé
parfait si tous les élèves ont au moins
deux séances d'équitation par semaine le
cheval est également enseigner de façon
théorique
au programme de ces terminal un cours
d'hippologie sur les parasites
est ce que vous pouvez me citer quelques
parasites que vous connaissez yann la
douve du foie
le thème du cheval est présent dans tous
les cours du français aux maths et pour
de nombreux élèves
c'est une vraie raison d'aimer l'école
sans de cheval je pense aurait été
différent je chante avec les chevaux qui
se trouve à côté de notre cas ça nous
permettent plus de motiver je pense que
c'est ce qu'ils permettent aussi de
justement d'avoir la capacité de travail
et puis efficacement cas alors voilà
fait réglées vous avez la dose
après la théorie pas de temps mort un
cobaye et déjà la porte de la classe
pour une prise de vermifuges allait
entièrement entièrement les pieds voulu
maintenir la tête en retrait peu en
l'air mais pour beaucoup de jeunes la
première motivation et d'améliorer son
niveau d'équitation
fabien fait d'être à proximité des
chevaux toutes les semaines tous les
jours je me suis dit que ça pourrait me
permettre d'évoluer à cheval encore plus
que dans un centre caisse classique
parce que le rythme est plus intensif
ici ont depuis souvent on fait pas les
mêmes exercices et on n'a pas les mêmes
moniteur qu'ailleurs retour à la
pratique avec des étudiants de niveau
bac + 3 qui prépare une licence en
management des centres équestres donc là
ce qu'on est en train de voir ces des
chevaux qui montre la petite marche au
pas pour apprendre à apprendre le temps
de le faire bien savoir analyser le
terrain pour savoir où poser leurs pieds
et une fois que je crois ont compris ça
ils comprennent que ça leur fait pas mal
que ça leur fait pas peur et ensuite on
pourra le faire à vitesse un petit peu
plus important
exercice du jour initiée de jeunes
chevaux au franchissement des obstacles
de cross pour ce travail
ils sont encadrés par un instructeur du
lycée formé à saumur ans qu'est le
tranquille tranquille point qu'ils sont
et d'objets / t2 y est allé voilà là tu
mets un petit peu la jambe pour le
renvoyer en avant
le dressage des poulains demande déjà
une bonne expérience
ces étudiants bénéficient aussi pendant
leurs années de formation de cours de
comptabilité de gestion et des stages
techniques avec de grands cavaliers
jamais eu la chance de faire des
formations professionnelles dès la 3eme
même après j'ai toujours été dans
l'enseignement général et du coup d'être
là au milieu des chevaux et de voir tous
ces jeunes qui sont 24 heures sur 24
avec des chaussées c'est super
coût de la formation à l'année pour les
collégiens et les lycéens 3500 euros
avec l'internât et les cours
d'équitation les chevals un métier
d'avenir et bien plus encore c'est une
des valeurs fondamentales le respect de
soi des autres du cheval de l'animal
avec une bonne connaissance du monde
agricole avec une bonne connaissance du
monde équestre
donc comme je parle de deux cultures
agricoles et de cultures équestres ça me
semble fondamental pour bien évoluer et
dans la vie et dans leur métier futur
quel qu'il soit pour quelques
privilégiés comme les à la jeune et
l'oise
le bonheur c'est d'avoir son propre
cheval au sein du lycée
c'est vraiment c'est un plaisir énorme
et faut vraiment être passionné pour
pour un livre pourquoi vivre ce qu'on
vit ce et puis voilà on rencontre des
personnes qui nous dira jamais c'est bon
pour moi c'est une famille ben ali c'est
une folie 85 % des élèves du lycée du
cheval réussissent leurs examens et 96 %
trouvent un emploi à la fin de leurs
études